gisèle halimi avocate des figures du
féminisme
nous ne sommes pas qu'un corps nous
sommes un coeur une
sensibilité une intelligence une
histoire
défendre les droits des femmes c'était
le combat de sa vie
1972 début du procès très médiatisé de
bobigny sur le banc des accusés une
mineure marie claire chevallier jugé
pour avoir avorté après un viol
à l'époque lives et j est illégal gisèle
halimi tu défends la jeune femme et
obtient sa relaxe au delà de défendre
les victimes l'avocate veut aller plus
loin elle veut changer la loi je crois
que les juges ont été troublés par ce
débat qui a été fait est que il faut
dire ils n'ont pas fait ce je le
regrette personnellement je les engagés
à faire le bape saut qualitatif prendre
la responsabilité c'est leur droit et
c'est leur devoir c'est aux juges de
changer la loi et d'indiquer qu'elle ne
peut plus être arrêté
1975 l'appel est entendu la loi veil est
votée li vg légaliser trois ans plus
tard en 1978 nouveau procès et nouveau
combat pour l'avocate engagé dernière
journée du procès des violeurs à aix en
provence trois hommes sont jugés pour le
viol collectif de deux femmes encore une
fois qui prend la défense des victimes
gisèle halimi
bousculés mais déterminé gisèle halimi
obtient la condamnation des violeurs ce
procès entraîne le vote d'une nouvelle
loi en 1981 le viol qui était jusque-là
un délit devient un crime et gisèle
halimi continue son combat féministe
sans relâche octobre 1982 celle qui est
devenue députée manifeste pour le
remboursement de l'ibg est taxé
opposants
deux fois d'arrière-garde elle était
derrière l'ordre quand elle voulait
empêcher les femmes de choisir le moment
de leur maternité elle est deux fois
plus d'arrière-garde tante qui veulent
les empêcher d'avoir le droit au
remboursement
deux mois plus tard nouvelle avancée
lives et j'ai remboursé grâce à la loi
roudy après la légalisation de l'ibg
puis son remboursement autre combat pour
gisèle halimi
1989 c'est la sphère des foulards de
creil la militante féministe s'oppose au
port du voile à l'école publique quand
ios racisme apporte son soutien aux
collégiennes de creil gisèle halimi
quitte l'association c'est un des signes
de l'enfer où on a fait venir pas que ça
ça fait partie d'un tout la charia la
loi coranique et qui met la femme drôle
de sujet très les répudier on peut il ya
la polygamie elle veut pas témoigner
gisèle halimi se battra aussi contre la
prostitution tout au long de sa vie elle
continuera de défendre les droits des
femmes elle est morte le 28 juillet 2020
à l'âge de 93 ans
[Musique]